berlin einen wunderschönen guten abend
von uns beiden ja wir haben was zu
feiern ein historisches ereignis an
einem historischen ort hier stand sie
wie wir alle wissen die mauer vor 30
jahren ist sie zu fall gebracht worden
von den menschen in der ddr und man kann
es nicht oft genug dazu sagen mit
friedlichen mitteln
wir konnten damals nicht sagen was wir
wollten wir konnten nicht machen was wir
wollten und wir konnten nicht wohin wir
wollten wir die bürger der ddr wurden
überwacht bevormundet und eingesperrt
und die bürger haben sich dagegen
gewehrt haben sich aufgelehnt
man muss ja ganz klar sagen es war nicht
einfach das rad der geschichte dass sich
da gedreht hat es war nicht einfach der
lauf der dinge sondern es waren die
menschen die etwas gewagt haben
wir haben heute abend viele viele tolle
künstler auf der bühne und es kommen
menschen zu wort die diese wende damals
mitgestaltet haben und jetzt begrüßen
sie mit mir unseren gastgeber begrüßen
sie den regierenden bürgermeister von
berlin herzlich willkommen michaela
genau vor 30 jahren fiel die berliner
mauer es war eine friedliche revolution
mit der die menschen in ostdeutschland
sich erhoben ein aufbegehren das
gewaltlos aber voller wucht war und dass
nicht nur die mauer sondern mit ihr das
sed regime zu fall brachte hier und an
vielen anderen orten in unserer stadt
ereigneten sich nach dem mauerfall
szenen des glücks die niemand der sie
miterlebt hat nie vergessen wird
[Musik]
du hast mich befragen
doch ein 20
dazu macht
[Musik]
so meine damen und herren begrüßen sie
jetzt hier auf der bühne unseren
bundespräsidenten herzlich willkommen
frank walter steinmeier
[Applaus]
was für ein anblick von hier oben viele
so viele sind gekommen hier ans
brandenburger tor dieses tor das so
lange ein symbol der teilung unseres
landes war heute ist es ein anderes ein
symbol der einheit und freiheit ein
symbol für ein starkes land und für eine
weltoffene stadt guten an berlin
unsere gedanken sind heute auch bei
unseren freunden in polen ungarn
tschechien und der slowakei
ihr mut hat den menschen in
ostdeutschland mut gemacht
ihr mut hat die teilung europas beendet
wir danken euch dafür
die vielen nicht einfach auch ein
starker arm aus dem westen war am werk
ich sehe noch vor mir sonne dragon hier
vor dem brandenburger tor
und ich höre noch sein wort theron sie
liebe gäste diesem amerika verdanken wir
deutschen viel und dieses amerika als
partner in gegenseitigem respekt als
partner für demokratie und freiheit
gegen nationalen egoismus das wünsche
ich mir auch in zukunft
auch dafür steht der neunter november es
steht für den aufbruch in die erste
deutsche demokratie für die ausrufung
der republik vor gut einem jahrhundert
aber der neunter november erinnert auch
an die zerstörung dieser ersten
deutschen demokratie erinnert an die
absturz in die barbarei an brennende
synagoge an die verfolgung und ermordung
der europäischen juden spätestens
allerspätestens nach dem anschlag von
halle haben offen hoffentlich alle in
diesem land begriffen die jahre vergehen
die vergangenheit rückt in die ferne
jahr aber dass nie wieder der kampf
gegen rassenhass und antisemitismus
diese verantwortung sie vergeht nicht
meine damen und herren
geschichte besteht aus geschichten und
geschichte unseres landes ist die das
unseren geschichten besteht aus ihren
geschichten sie alle haben ihre ganz
eigenen erinnerungen an die zeit vor 30
jahren haben ihre eigenen erinnerungen
auch an das zusammenwachsen von ost und
west und ich wünsche mir erzählen wir
einander unsere geschichten vor allem
hören wir einander zu und noch wichtiger
nehmen wir uns gegenseitig ernst meine
damen und herren
[Musik]
die freiheitsrevolution vom oktober 1989
die mauer zum einsturz brachte hat keine
menschenleben gefordert dafür sind wir
dankbar
aber ich möchte auch und gerade heute
hier inmitten dieser großen bunten feier
an all die menschen erinnern deren leben
in den 40 jahren der die sed diktatur
zerstört wurde
oder die es ganz verloren haben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
seine worte wieder da
auf und da freut mich noch eine saison
auch wenn davon nicht auch eine saison
[Musik]
aber ehrlich wäre auf und davon nicht
auf eine saison auf und davon nicht
alte schule steilen kurve immer gegner
folgte geht dorthin wo war noch hätten
und es werde jahre zu ende sind
wie mag dass es ein gutes ende
mit
vergangen kaum gutes los
freude währt wird gut
[Musik]
j
als über
schönen guten abend geladen meine damen
und herren wunderbar hier zu sein heute
abend vielen dank an vielen dank jochen
zwei zeugen werden sich erinnern an
diesen neunter november und dann die
zeit darüber hinaus ich freue mich sie
ihn vorstellen zu dürfen das ist jutta
seidel die schon 1982 in der ddr die
frauen für den frieden mit gegründet hat
und später kontakt suchte zu den
internationalen ärzten zur verhütung des
atomkriegs und auf der anderen seite
steht michael heinisch kirsch auch er
gehörte zur protestbewegung im umfeld
der evangelischen kirche und war bei den
kontrollen der letzten kommunalwahlen
der ddr dabei von denen sich dann
herausstellte sie waren gefälscht ohne
die bürgerrechtsbewegung wäre die mauer
nicht gefallen und die ddr nicht ins
wanken geraten ihnen beiden also heute
abend ein ganz herzliches willkommen von
uns allen
guten tag sie waren damals 25 jahre alt
wie viel hatte der mauerfall mit ihrem
protest mit dem protest einer
unzufriedenen jugend in der ddr zu tun
ja wir gingen wir waren wirklich nicht
viele wir gingen seit einem halben jahr
ja vorher auch schon mal zu
verschiedenen anlässen auf die straße
verließen kirchliche räume haben
demonstriert wenn man heute
demonstrationen denkt denkt man ein
hunderte tausende zehntausende menschen
wir waren vielleicht 20 oder 30
vielleicht 50 immer am 7 eines jeden
monats haben wir uns getroffen um zu
demonstrieren meistens gegen den
wahlbetrug ja und dadurch hatte sich das
eingebürgert am siebten ist
demonstrationen und am 7 oktober war es
dann auf einmal einer massenbewegung
also die zeit war reif frau sei
die leute riefen ja da auf der
bornholmer straße wir kommen wieder
worum ging es in dieser nacht ging es um
reisefreiheit ging es darum dass man
eben mal den kudamm sieht oder ging es
schon auch für sie um das vereinte
deutschland
es ging glaube ich ganz viel darum
einfach mal zu gucken ob das stimmt was
da gesagt worden war und ob da noch mehr
leute
vielleicht auch mal wieder zu gucken
also ich kann mich gut erinnern dass vor
mir auf dem weg zur bornholmer brücke
der bornholmer straße zwei frauen liefen
total aufgeregt mit stöckelschuhen und
sich gegenseitig bestätigten dass sie
morgen unbedingt wieder am arbeitsplatz
sein wollen und nummer gucken wollen
also ich denke es ging darum nur mal zu
sehen ob das stimmt dann war ja so eine
tolle stimmung auf dieser brücke ich bin
noch nie so oft hoch gehoben worden
wir trafen da viele bekannte und
irgendwie war immer der impuls da sich
zu bewegen irgendwas da irgendwie seine
freude auszudrücken
das war eine kollektive freude die dies
wahrscheinlich so nie wieder geben wird
[Applaus]
[Musik]
red
[Applaus]
[Musik]